hey buddy hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to horns of fear
okay let's do this horns of fear for the
best gameplay experiences recommend that
you play the game in a dark room while
using headphones I've heard that before
and I was misled down a road that caused
me to have a lot of problems with my
camera so we're not gonna talk about
that and we're gonna okay I guess I
gotta hit the skip skip but we're not
gonna talk about that a Saturday evening
in Jim's son remorse abhorrent oh it's a
top down game I haven't played a
top-down game like this in ages well I
guess technically the RPG horror maker
games are top-down but this is different
the fridge is empty that's so sad I
don't feel like cooking right now I
don't feel like cooking I don't feel
like cooking all right I like the
styling of it that is pretty cool yeah
that's not bad
alright I'm into you I won't open your
menu oh [ __ ] in certain parts of the
game the many puzzles etc you must use
the mouse to interact Jim will only pick
up items if he needs them whenever you
need to use an item open your menu and
click on the item oh is that the family
the family still alive click back okay
cool alright I'll take a shower later
yeah good use these machines pizza beans
so alright thanks a lot bye thank you I
guess sit down at your desk to eat
alright good I don't have a dining table
okay alright then my name is Jim Sundra
Nora
I'm 36 years old isn't that sad I take
care of myself work out every morning
avoid eating too much meat i watch
Seinfeld every Saturday night such a
good show my parents insisted I studied
journalism they were right to do so has
I'm one of the best in the field me I
wanted to become an artiste paint
creatures all day long while lighting up
you mean lighting up like like in you
want to sing like a weed
my wife Brenda and daughter Maria's
sweet as could be I want for nothing
it's your typical well-ordered life but
I feel as if I'm floating downriver with
barely any nipples just waiting to grow
old I need something else on board and
that is probably why I'm talking to you
right now
my old imaginary friend just like all of
you you're all my imaginary friend you
don't really exist right you're all just
in my head
right just talking that's something I
haven't done with my wife in ages apart
from the insults we've slung at each
other the last few days well that's not
it sounds like you want for something
after hitting a wall with me she decided
to take Murray to a hotel for a few days
to re-evaluate things so I sit here at
home kept company by cold pizza and an
array of pills to keep me submerged in
my own maze-like subconscious oh this
guy's the kind of guy that would poster
are I am very smart on reddit I've been
taking them for a few weeks now ah time
to take my pill let's give this one a
try that's some good [ __ ] right there
hello did i vom or did i do something
else hello excuse my rasp I do apologize
for calling so late I'm trying to reach
Jim's son oh there's a different person
I'm trying to reach Jim Sandra Moore the
reporter who specializes in the
paranormal this is me he how can I help
you I miss Oh
I'm mrs. Gordon you contacted us last
week about your next article on the
paranormal it's true there have been
rumors about strange things happening in
the vicinity
since you seem intent on seeing the
property for yourself why don't you come
right on over tell her I don't over
right now we'll leave the door open for
you
how long be available much longer hmm
all right then I'll be over shortly
horns ephyra okay I like the music
I do like music the music is quite nice
yeah he's tripping balls going up to
this place this is definitely 207 I know
my numbers but nobody's answering
huh the door is open they did leave it
open for me hmm hello anyone home I
don't like the look at this place they
got a Salt Rock lamp I can lick that a
few times the only thing these computers
can do is save data that's it why did we
buy so many of these old relics nice art
save and data okay cool that's cool
this painting is in rough shape the
man's face has eaten away by mold but
they seemed to love each other
regardless is it is it eaten away by
mold in real-life roads in the painting
a statuette of a cat with a livid glazed
gaze glaze glaze huh oh no comment I
suppose worms and beetles share a heap
of rotting meat this is bizarre this
stench is horrific oh hi buddy oh you're
alive oh I'm Jim Sanremo the journalist
sorry to bother you
oh he doesn't seem very accommodating
I'll come back later ask about himself
you seem concerned about something can I
can I help which is not communicating
okay I came here after receiving a phone
call I don't think he's listening well
let's see what's gonna happen
could you tell me more about the rumors
surrounding this place not like I
expected a constructive response have
you been on the property for a very long
okay don't know why I expect anything
you never know
that could have sparked an interesting
conversation yep okay well frankly I
thought you were just a corpse in a
wheelchair I didn't even know that you
were I still don't over your life that's
the face my daughter makes when I take
away her phone Matt Matt Matt not
official plan nothing unusual this game
is pretty cool I like it a lot ah snake
equals f hmm now if I know my alphabet f
is not for snake o is not for triangle
either so fool me once shame on you
oh well that's not right
oh this is all over the place oh well
this is just wrong wrong wrong cross
everything oh this is terrible terrible
terrible all right someone in the chat
remember this like just absolutely
memorize this okay okay cool Wow
Oh are all these originals a painting of
Medusa decapitated by Perseus her gaze
has me literally frozen in place okay
for some reason the lovely Mona Lisa is
making a little nervous oh maybe that's
maybe that was why okay the owners
clearly have an affinity for painted art
yeah and somehow they're able to afford
all these multi-million dollar paintings
oh I'm giving very uh what was a game
called something living nightmares or
neverending nightmares I'm getting very
never-ending nightmare [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
all right that's not it's gonna be Oh
ha hi hello
oh hi hello I'm the German Ellis Jim
Sanremo I got a late night phone call
inviting me to come visit I just let
myself in Arian Gordon oh yeah I heard
some about you you're writing an article
about weird crapper whatever rot that's
the basic idea
oh do you think we're creepy I'm
actually more interested in the rumors
about this building I'm not here to
offend anyone I'm just messing with you
man
okay so Aryan I take your your phone the
Gordon's daughter is that info you using
your article for the introduction
possibly I don't really like talking
about myself IRL to be honest follow me
on Twitter if you want to learn more you
sound just like my daughter does she
like surfing the Deep Web too no anyway
I think we're getting outside of the
scope of my investigation okay
I'm sure you've spotted my dad Joseph in
the wheelchair he's an odd man mostly
keeps to himself since the accident I
see I'm surprised your mother didn't
greet me at the door could you tell me
about her Diane's pretty overbearing and
demand and especially when it comes to
my education school it isn't really my
jam you know where can I find it most
likely in the forest your mom already
forgot I was stopping by
who knows until she came back from her
walk you could look around the area if
you haven't already oh I almost forgot
hopefully you're not scared of dogs
because there's a good chance you'll
meet nibble mmm don't worry sweetheart
okay I don't like the orchestral swell
of music in the background over there
let's cut to the chase shall we
this was a long time ago the former
owners of the mansion the village
butcher and her husband I'm gonna get
out of that Backson had been living
peacefully for several years oh this
game is so cool then one day a circus
set up not far from the mansion
during a visit to the circus the husband
met Miranda a beautiful romeny woman who
practiced the occult quickly falling in
love the pair began meeting late at
night at the edge of the lake deep in
the woods right next to the mansion to
do what but the butcher eventually found
out and she was furious the next day
when Miranda was expecting to see her
beloved once more oh she instead saw the
butcher wielding a hefty cleaver above
her head oh [ __ ] a single blow tore
through the calm night as she lay dying
the occultist cursed her attacker
along with mansion not long after the
husband became very so your mother
singing very lovely
[Music]
how long after the husband became very
ill so how exactly does his curse
manifest you get this tightness in your
rib cage a shadow stretches over the
ground trying to grab you then there's
the caretaker
who's that I'd rather not talk about
that I need to know more thanks for the
information Ariane okay so the forest
belongs to the Gordon family right
personally with everything that happened
here decades ago I tend to avoid the
place especially at night I've got a
maintenance man Mr Dedalus he's sort of
a handyman takes care of the forest and
you can thank em for creating all the
mechanisms in the mansion his inventions
are fascinating I'd like to check out
the woods the only way there is through
the lock door at the back of the mansion
and just so happens I have the key
then please lend it to me let's make a
little deal ah yeah I like making deals
you find the wooden cow Daedalus made
for me Daedalus and then I'll help you
a wooden cow I won't try and guess
what's so important about it but okay
sure
no how would you just give it to me why
do I have to go running around for a
wooden cow oh this is this weird I like
it though I tasted this dog food once
when I was a kid honestly it wasn't half
bad I don't doubt that I guess why is
this wait wait no wait wait wait no wait
no I don't like what this implies I
don't like I do not like nope
don't like that implication nope no I
don't think that's a good idea
right there putting all the pieces in
the correct order won't unlock any
mechanisms it'll just scar you for life
all right is this like the actual myth
of the Minotaur this lady put herself in
a hollowed-out fake female cow presented
her bum bum straight for the opening
here a cow a bozo
how are you doing and then that's the
real story no way that's horrible
horrible yeah I went there
you like chips do your hair
little girl you like chips yeah so I
gotta go find a wooden cow but something
tells me I really really really don't
want to wouldn't go so the order is the
symbols right the orders the symbols so
everyone remember this so a moon over
the valley of the mountains we've got
two people with big noses facing back to
back
we've got sperm and we've got a moon no
we've got a Bulls ring like a bull ring
like a big old bull ring in the nose
we've got moon over the mountain of two
valleys we got two big nose people
facing away from each other
we've got sperm and we've got big old
bull ring got it okay everybody remember
that don't forget that don't forget that
I love this I love this game I love this
game I am in love with this game this
game is so cool I love this game to be
or not to be to be or not to be to be or
not to be to be or not to be two old men
eating soup they have a deathly
complexion yeah they do to obey or not
the way the clock stopped at 8:00 that's
probably important art if you should
plan nothing unusual weird
all right okay that's nothing of
interest it's a model it's a model of a
cheerful clown man I hate clowns yeah
it's a it's a model okay oh they appear
to be fans of the painter Francisco de
Goya and his black paintings in
particular Oh somebody added elements to
this fusilli piece man there's a lot of
like artistic stuff going on here I
don't know my art something's missing
what's missing I'm not a hundred percent
sure what's missing but something's
missing okay man okay big holes in the
ground I don't have anything to say
about that all right okay I'll just move
on then nothing weird about this man
this bizarre hate
everything about this room minute or
minute or project soon they will be
legion they will spread chaos the state
must not survived and the corruption in
lies now the note comes with a small key
got a small key alright statue it is a
slight look of despair good ol mannequin
buts doll heads looks to be some kind of
mechanism but it needs batteries to work
another clown its model of a cheerful
clown man I hate your definition of
cheerful you must be high as a kite man
because this is just weird okay I was
watching that clown like a hawk oh well
I don't know what those are alright
whatever it's so many there's so many
different puzzles here so many different
puzzles Saturn has a strangely strange
notion of fatherly love it was with all
the different gods eating their own
children that that's a little bizarre
that's a little bizarre I gotta admit
that's a little bizarre but yeah what
the [ __ ] oh I love this surreal 'no sat
this game - this is satanic ritual oh i
oh this is probably what's tying in to
all of those letters from that book like
the different versions of it so i don't
know what to do with this just yet so
i'm not gonna I'm not gonna do anything
with it but it's all part of a big
puzzle so I don't know what I'm gonna be
able to do that the woods extend as far
as the eye can see do they now there's a
shell casing in one of the pockets of
this jacket nothing huge nothing useful
huh
okay nothing useful yet maybe I might
need that Oh God
nothing of interest really nothing of
interest these beautiful statues nothing
of interest they're part official plan
nothing unusual nothing unusual it's
locked okay
oh that's right I need to get the wooden
cow before I'm able to do that where was
a wooden cow - haven't been everywhere
yet I definitely haven't been anywhere
this this place is big [ __ ] but I have
not been everywhere okay you know this
place is really weird right like living
in this place is not cool anyway okay
alright what the hell
the puppeteer looks grim yeah the
puppeteer looks grim I see a slot in the
middle here alright nothing else to say
about that so I'm controlling the
movements of a test subject
bear all right okay you didn't even see
that that was over my face what the [ __ ]
something in the bathroom just went
horrible I'm sorry you missed that what
the [ __ ]
all right there was no way that I got a
predictor that nice taxidermy work I
feel like you could attack me at any
second Oh more clowns this'll be me if I
keep popping those pills yeah maybe
captain the hold is packed with exotic
fish and bottles of rum
we should weigh anchor before the sea
monster pulls us into the deep okay it's
not a clue it's a large transparent
sheet that reads Henry Fuseli Macbeth
I'm gonna need this apparently I'm gonna
need this print burn sheet this fish
tank could use a lot more care waters
green and the dead fish floating on the
murky surface don't want to stare this
bed too long I'm tired as hell cute dog
my daughter would love to have one like
it well why did you go over to this
place in the dead of night
yeah the exact same rocking horse as a
kid is that a clue that a clue exact
same wear on yours is like something
about your childhood is that some weird
thing about that oh maybe I can actually
know I can get down there okay all right
then there's a slimy liquid at the
bottom of the bathtub god it stinks
nasty set of dentures in the think I
think I could use it for something
really you think you could use dentures
for something maybe give the old man
some dentures I can't make much out in
this dim light okay good to know
oh this is so weird it's like it's just
like a bizarre haunted oh hey hey hey I
found the fun room all right a bonsai in
an old photo stand on this dusty piece
of furniture all I'm gonna find them is
better suspicious stains hey I ain't
complaining about nothing knows his
business Dane's hmm
hmm something's vibrating in whose arm
wha
I don't even want to know you may not
but I do hmm
a bedpan that's a little weird all right
here's a painting I like now this I like
this all right
it's an old handheld radio the batteries
inside could be useful what the [ __ ]
it's kind of got like also a resident
evil vibe to it no that's a lie that's a
lie
wait
what the hell where am I
could this be from one of the pills I
took earlier hi hey there how you doing
my name is markiplier how are you avenge
me what hey listen here my head ally Wow
I love it I love it I love it I love it
I love everything about it I love this
game this game so cool let's go so
[ __ ] cool all right so we got
dentures I'm thinking if we give them to
the old man the old man will suddenly be
able to make some kind of logical sense
is there a hole a dog why are you
donning like that huh Monalisa hey do
you do anything about it
okay hey old man that looks like a
corpse I got some dentures do I need to
actually like you dentures hands the
dentures to the old man perfect okay
gross Oh
I am sorry I enabled that I am I deeply
regret everything I did make that happen
he fell asleep with a full stomach oh
did he
oh he did oh that's cute
oh that's adorable oh oh but I can go in
here now that's that's real nice
okay nothing of interest don't wanna
stare at this bed too long I'm tired as
hell
everything's normal here hunky-dory the
loo dude I can see some wooden items
behind this old rotten door the wooden
cow is there let's try this caboose key
sweet I don't know why I went oh okay
don't know why wind come out a key come
at a cabaret scene there wooden cow
great okay something Bad's gonna happen
down here let's prompt hey what boy
don't show me your teeth Oh touchdown Oh
die matter baby
what I'm zipper do it oh my god oh my
god my head oh my god no oh I'm here
okay I'm good all right okay I shouldn't
have stuck around so much huh down I'm
so surprised oh hi old man Oh
again my head what about this old man
okay I don't know what about what's what
what do i do what do I do
really yeah show me [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you game I could have
I was I was pressing down I was oh
darling you got a really that's gonna
trick him that tricks him really that
trick some that trick some that tricks
him Oh old man you just got into bed in
the how did you wait how'd you get your
wheelchair down here what the hell oh
man you're just gonna go to bed I guess
the old man he's sleeping peacefully I
bet he is I just bet I bet he is
oh what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
hey wait a minute
hey wait a minute I didn't sign up for
that that's not right I'm sign up for
that or that or that wait do I have
anything to say about these clear I have
an affinity for painted art you know I
love Leah Mona Liz is making me a little
nervous okay all right pour is gonna
move on it pretend like that ain't
nothing no don't split my head open oh
my god press faster left no and dirt
left oh I did it
Oh what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] oh jeez the nice dinner oh
the doors damned on me save I guess all
right Wow um okay yeah I'll the lovely
dinner got all SQUOZE okay nothing to
say about it though and nothing to say
about what just happened we're just
gonna mosey on like nothing happened or
she's gonna move forward and continue on
with our life because that's what we do
here now was the name is game horns of
fear where's Ariana I hope she's safe I
need to find her yeah well you know the
old man didn't seem too worried about
its whoa ah
plus the Poochie so that's the guy who
attacked me plus the Poochie there okay
but what did I get
okay the question is what I got I have
the wooden cow and I need to find her so
let me see if I can go find her I'm
gonna check the other rooms over here
and then I'm gonna go up maybe in one of
these rooms maybe in this room although
she probably shouldn't be in this room
maybe in this room oh there she is hey
did you see a murderous face ripping
[ __ ] or honey er Aaron are you okay
did did you see the caretaker Christ
sick that was the caretaker he tried to
kill me he shouldn't have gone the
cellar he's really angry now I'm scared
and my dog's nowhere to be found
I'd like to have him with me you could
have warned me I only went into the
cellar to get your stupid cow
sorry here's the key I promised
okay the carrots taker seems close to
your father
yeah he washes over Joseph I don't know
why you never told the authorities about
this the caretaker can disappear into
the shadows how do you catch something
so elusive cops can't do anything about
a curse and they wouldn't understand
anyway can't you just leave the mansion
if only it was that simple I have to get
to the bottom of this anything else I
should know if you go into the woods be
sure to stay on the path
there's tons of traps in the tall grass
mr. Daedalus sent them to catch animals
hmm okay so that was the caretaker huh
okay fine by me Oh dead load Andy let's
go I don't know where we're gonna go
okay so I've got I've gotten out like
two key things one of this is like a
windy whoo batteries a normal key some
trigonometry and emotive photo of my
family no nope nope we just need to go
back there [ __ ]
[Music]
okay was there something over here there
was something with that painting of the
finale guy the fennel Allah the Fenella
Lilla the the full Allah Allah the
fillol Aloha this guy okay fusilli I
have a fusilli something Jim must
correctly place a plastic sheet over the
painting ah okay so alright so these
guys wait oh wait this triangles in
there oh wait there's triangles in their
hands right here ooh what does this mean
I don't know what this means what does
this mean
okay what does this mean okay Oh a d4 ah
four d f-- d 4 I think d4 okay d4 got it
okay well I got that and I know d4 now
that's real handy that's handy dandy
okay these needed batteries okay he's
batteries so put batteries in there use
the batteries to get the mechanism
working okay now what does it do hate it
oh I hate it oh wait XIV according to
the book that need a certain a certain
like thing there so okay are they just
letters oh man they're all the letters
okay that's weird
okay so I don't know this just yet ah
but it is telling me the clue okay so
we're gonna go back to the book in the
main area we're gonna look at this and
we're gonna come back here so XIV oh it
already opened it so remember it was
mountain over moon well I don't
Oh b c d e f g h i j k okay so b c d e f
f is it gonna spell [ __ ] okay it was
this one and then it was two big noses
okay JK's so FJ f j sperm FJ b c FJ b c
FJ b c FJ b c i got FJ b c hell yeah
hell yeah
FJ b c FJ b c o FJ b c o FJ b c we got
this FJ b c oh yeah we got this FJ p c
FJ b c FJ b c we got this FJ you and me
FJ b c we got this oh yeah FJ b c FJ p c
FJ b c FJ b c FJ b c stands for fun
jolly big [ __ ] that's me that's what
they call me FJ b see mr. fun jumping
away okay I hate that I hate that even
more hello
it's a model of a cheerful clown has
this ass gaped wider to know okay thank
you
I've got a Libra thing I'm not a Libra
but okay I can't use it here all right
well I have that maybe I could fit that
in the slot with like the octopus or
something and this was d4 so I gotta
remember that everybody remember d4
better but no balloon around okay token
in the blue in the pot because they got
checked hey couldn't you shut it okay if
I couldn't put that in I can definitely
put the token and an octopus thing D for
blue oh that's a good point D for blue D
for blue D for blue to call and put the
coin in the slot it's perfectly hell
yeah it does okay oh okay so we should
oh wait nope the pirate the message
there was a message here this was it no
it was up here that's right wait hang on
captain the hold is packed with fish and
bottles of rum we should weigh anchor
that is pirate fish bottle anchor that's
what that is pirate fish bottle anchor
red red blue red red red blue red pirate
fish bottle anchor red red blue red
pirate fish bottle anchor pirate fish
bottle anchor red red blue red pirate
fish bottle anchor pirate fish bottle
but that's not red red blue
I find Poseidon what a Poseidon Poseidon
there that guy
no that's Jupiter that's Jupiter paws
are down policy isn't it
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I'm gonna
put it down here oh I hate that oh
that's the worst thing I've ever seen oh
that's awful that is [ __ ] up on every
level
[Music]
okay so I did pass it
without Saturn this one is for this
Buzzard
I got a Taurus alright I got that okay
so I got the Taurus and Libra things and
I've got this windy thing but I've got
the key to the front door so I might as
well just her the Forester so I might as
well go up there even though that's
probably gonna end in my death yeah okay
I wasn't paying attention to that okay
the woods extent is about weird about
that totally fine all right it's all
good it's locked well good thing for me
I've got a key so I'm gonna just put
that bad boy in there and I'm gonna be
on my way hey buddy
the crazy guy lurking around things are
heating up for once and I'm not gonna
throw in the towel okay all right well
maybe you don't remember but I remember
your face getting split in half many
times oh something's missing
ah so this needs the the the the the
plates probably go here so if I can put
them here tablet use tablet use right so
I've got those better not spell out
another lady getting [ __ ] by a bowl
again oh no it's gonna look at this that
Bulls giving the this the lady the sexy
eyes none of that no yes you've been bad
you don't be bad don't be bad anyway we
got to find out where okay what about
this thing we don't really know this one
okay so is this one d 4 d 4 before blue
is that what this is but there's also
this gargoyle I'm not sure which oh
never mind okay okay so then the only
thing that's left is there's got to be
something that this uh this windy tool
goes to the clock that might be that
might need a winder hand let's try that
clock stopped at eight let's try the
winding eight oh that's not infinity
that's an eight okay
don't like it which I didn't do it okay
well I got the tablets so that was good
hey I'm making good progress that's the
thing about this game it seemed daunting
at first but I'm making good progress
real real real real real jolly progress
there you go please don't spell out
bestiality well just that easy huh okay
doesn't look like it's spelling out
bestiality but I don't like the way that
bull's looking at that lady I don't like
it but everything's okay so far alright
here we go
come on oh no he's stuck in a trap but
it's still moving save it save the
doggie what he can't be
[Music]
oh no I can't leave it suffering I can't
let it suffer I can't I can't let it
suffer oh I'm gonna cry oh I cried you
couldn't leave it just like their if it
can't be saved
I believe it like oh no I hate that okay
stop it god damn it stop it okay this is
carry on cuz uh hi how you doing
hello I'm Jim Sam Rimmer a journalist
Shh see it what are you talking about
that little bastard of a squirrel he's
driving me up a tree squirrel meat is a
more distinct flavor than rabbit or
chicken it's a real treat forgive me I
forgot my manners
I'm mr. Daedalus pleased to me miss Jim
Morrison Jim Morrison wait I thought the
crazy guy was mr. Daedalus
it's Sandra Moore Jim Sandra Moore okay
traps you don't think maybe you've set
me too many traps somebody could get
hurt or Ariens dog could get caught in
one of them but wait like [ __ ] you man
don't tell me the dog oh poor thing we
shouldn't tell area and what really
happened Oh whatever you do stay on the
trails oh oh you [ __ ] it was you you
[ __ ] douche goddamnit [ __ ] you the
forest is crawling with all manner of
beasts I don't think anyone will mind if
I harvest a few to prepare delicious
meal for myself anyway our carved wooden
figurines representing the animals I
kill it's a way of giving them thanks
you killed a cow out here what you also
carved a wooden cow for air in that's
right we had a cow a few years ago an
Arian loved it so was an accident I
swear a lot of accidents seem to happen
around you man what's the story behind
all the mechanisms in the mansion the
Gorton's are quite fond of puzzles in
all forms being creative I thought to
provide a number of puzzles for them to
solve still it's a little inconvenient
having to find several tablets just to
go into the forest that's a special key
that allows you to unlock each puzzle if
you're in a hurry hmm that doesn't help
much tell me about your employers - gave
me plenty of leeway on most things the
mechanisms are traps have you noticed
anything odd about them I suppose you
one thing
juicy details or get this Diana Diane
keeps lovers she takes them on nighttime
strolls through the woods ending up in
the old cabin east of here
considering the screams I sometimes hear
it wouldn't surprise me if they were
into sadomasochism you've been a real
help
you've been a real help buddy mind if I
take your shovel need to bury the dog
dead rodents okay you know mr. Dedalus I
do not like you not at all
this game is good at creating a
narrative that suddenly gets me invested
in something I didn't think I was gonna
get invested in I mean I really didn't
man what is this oh oh this is important
okay
- ding - shh-shh remember that good all
mechanisms I sure do love up puzzle he
told me to go east so I'm gonna go east
first and then I'm gonna go wherever I'm
gonna go toe Dangs
dang Oh string equals two trumpets okay
well this is what I needed but okay can
i click on this nah can't even click on
this okay that's this instructions but
guitar equals two trumpets all right I'm
sure oh like what the [ __ ]
okay I guess it's just that's it then
all right thank you for the helpful info
oh really
why did I do what do I do
am i easy oh my god oh my god why do I
do
why did that happen and I'm fine
[ __ ] your game alright guess that's it
then
Oh what is this oh I don't know this
puzzle okay so I can't go here I can't
go into the BDSM Shack just yet
I gotta go probably north to do the
musical puzzle of some sort I guess oh
wait no you're totally right about that
you're totally right the the shapes
right you're so right there's something
buried here I need a tool to dig it up
can I get air shovel you're totally
right the musical symbols were connected
to those things right the sounds were
associated with the shapes there were
shapes around that tree I get it now
okay you're totally right and by that I
mean I'm totally right I knew that all
along
you all are dumb and you just are
leeching off my wisdom I am the bat no
this envis and actually my intelligence
to yelling at you remotely think is the
moat and tire existing okay so two
wearing mango two circles so it's
elusive circle air truck triangle Circle
Square Circle it's incredible it is
unbelievably and unkind and easing in
any oh other amazingness and without me
but unable to even wipe your own ass
okay hoot Tang from ting
all right good nothing there all right
well it seems like a lovely place a
painting of the scourge of Carpathia all
right who lit this fire by the way a
thick layer of dust covers the mirror
all right
sitting in the old chair here no okay
nothing of interest nothing of interest
all right Oh
tic-tac-toe oh it's one of these puzzles
oh I'm usually pretty good at this
ordinarily I've been known to go to the
grocery store there we go hello what are
you I'm guessing this is just an OCD
and what is that that I just got some
kind of crucifix thing a brooch Oh count
legends chapter JV let me move my screen
here Caleb like his Pierce was deprived
of everlasting peace while wandering the
arid land of damnation the demons gaze
met that of a beautiful woman despite
Caleb's monstrous appearance she fell
under his charm
damn didn't turned for offering her sold
Caleb the young woman now had to eat
human flesh in order to survive with a
dying breath she brought two children
into the world a girl and boy Caleb left
his children near a family of carnies
and then disappeared all right Caleb
sound like a dick bought okay whatever
you say oh my god I was that heart
attack sorry I'm a bit on edge at the
moment who are you and what are you
doing yeah I'm Jim Sandra Moore you must
be Diane you called me earlier did you
forget not at all I but I fell asleep
and I woke with a start and I heard you
alright okay what's the deal with the
caretaker he tried to slice my throat in
your cellar you mustn't go down there
that's where the caretaker brings my
husband to rest they have some sort of
connection but that's all I know
we could ambush him when he's in the
cellar you think we haven't tried that
thing can go through walls and vanish in
the dark it's not uncommon to see
objects which places are shadows making
obscene gestures on the walls I'm sure
we'll eventually go mad but we take that
risk and remain in this manner that
costs so many sacrifices I read some of
your articles on the paranormal and
thought perhaps you could help us
I'm not a ghost bus or anything but I
won't turn down a lively how lively
investigation I'll see what I can do
okay the forest is gorgeous but also a
little dangerous with all those traps
the traps are the work of our
maintenance man I can't complain the
meat is excellent okay you know all this
is the fault of the occultist [ __ ] who
put a curse on the area before dying the
[ __ ] the god damn [ __ ] Aryan told me
about it she didn't hear this sordid
tale until you moved here you can
imagine the real estate agent wasn't
about to share those details and I must
admit we've got the property at a
competitive price
that's so funny though last question
where is the body of the occultist she's
resting near the lake seeing as she's
the source of all these problems I'll go
take a look there good I have a few
things to attend to now watch yourself
ah
righty-ho thank you for all your help
there are cockroaches on this mattress
Xavier d-wade
uh-huh
Xavier D John W
Felix Kjellberg Kevin L mark EF me Sean
Mahalo and mark bababa I don't know
hmm dine locked door binder the weirdo
what is the point of that note I mean
it's got cool but what's the point of
the notes just a hit list
it's the grandmas coming to get me
that's pretty creepy though pretty
creepy gotta admit a little creepy
alright so I gotta go get the shovel
from the caretaker to dig up the remains
of the lady so I gotta go get the shovel
dig up maybe I need to go to the lake
first just to like so we can go like
Arnie there's a shop over this so you
know you never know what those things so
I'm gonna go up there I don't see that
you love you love Shawn me too man
there's something buried here I need a
tool to dig it up I've got a tool right
here me I'm the biggest tool there is
can I steal your shovel I'll just take
it then I guess yeah anything new to say
nope okay bye anyway did you know that
the grandma takes also she has lovers I
don't not not discrediting like elderly
people having sex but just like from the
screams I don't think she would be too
energetic to BDSM her way through
various lovers so I'm certain that she
was probably eating them according to
the hint there and she's probably the
butcher's wife if I'm gonna be perfectly
honest she's probably the butcher's wife
and this is actually the [ __ ] that uh
that is her husband was with I need a
duel well I got a duel right here
we go put that right in there
yeah bones you say I don't feel so good
it looks like part of his collars Minh
his his his his color I thought you said
this was the hue
I'm sorry I did that
I forgot that did Miranda need that to
rest in peace
[Music]
hi hello how you doing I'm gonna dodge
who are you ain't gonna give me I know I
know
whoa Oh
come on out oh [ __ ] it's going down oh
it's going [ __ ] down let's get this
over with
oh yeah [ __ ] oh I've been waiting for
this my whole life you go back to get
[ __ ] up oh you bout to get [ __ ] up
Oh get Oh I'm gonna whomp you out [ __ ]
I'll get ready to get oh oh wait no ow
[ __ ]
Oh what the [ __ ]
I don't think okay oh wait no I know I
know I got a dodge the attack first and
then hit him huh
yeah okay I got dodge miss me [ __ ] oh
yeah you you want to hit me but you
can't oh you know you want you missed me
miss me now you want to kiss me um come
here come here you bastard oh you [ __ ]
I'm gonna slap the [ __ ] I'm just gonna
take a lot longer than I suspected it
was gonna but I'm gonna get you oh you
you think oh you don't think oh you
think you don't think oh yeah yeah as a
kiss for good luck there Oh
oh wait um Oh
this place again the caretaker
disappeared but I doubt a shovel is
enough to get rid of them
okay
some kind of computer huh weird nope
okay well that's a long hallway but
what's over here huh what's over here
oh go down it okay I'll go down it oh
there we go then I guess I'm going down
it Oh hate it
no never mind don't want to be here I
changed my mind about everything don't
know why I'm here I don't hi Miranda you
need my aid huh am i trippin my brother
whom you call caretaker and myself we
are special all right
the shadow of our father the demons
Kaleb flows through our souls the
caretaker why does he want to kill me
he's charged with protecting my remains
as well as my love Joseph Joseph also
husband to the butcher the one who
murdered you by the lake
yes his soul is damned because he loved
me daughter if a demon you must feed on
human flesh to survive the butcher Diane
brings Joseph the meat he requires ah so
I was right so as I Anna murdered you
one of Diane's lover is about to be
sacrificed save him but how return to
the cabin why didn't you just ask your
brother to kill Diane she was near the
talisman that protects her to some
degree as my brother is recovering from
your confrontation he will have to deal
with Diane yourself Oh
Oh Oh I must return to the cabin
I guess I must do that I'm on the way
baby here to finish this once and for
all just a lively investigation for me
an everyday occurrence one that I care
nothing about here we go baby I'm coming
for you get ready for a face full of
[ __ ] this fist I'm gonna get you good
long road to go I like it maybe I
started maybe I started talking a little
too early there but I'm coming for you
baby you you think the dog Diane you
think you just go around calling people
[ __ ] that's no good that's no cool get
ready for a face full of [ __ ] this
fist I'm coming for you baby
okay forgot that there was another turn
there are time on the way baby I'm come
for you you're gonna get it well I'm
here okay alright well okay alright
Diane here comes the pain train ready to
give you a face full of [ __ ] this
fist we're coming for you baby whoa whoa
help me I beg you
oh okay Jesus did Diane do this to you
she's insane I'm not the first one she's
tortured she cut up a man with the saw
in the bathtub in the mansion I fell
into the clutches of the devil I'm
getting you out air the box controls a
torture device use it to free me okay
nothing of interest all right how you
doing buddy help me I beg you
okay nothing of interest okay Oh
oh ah oh [ __ ] okay oh God
okay okay that does a lot okay oh there
we go I got 70 there okay got that
that's good
duck down down yeah [ __ ] Clark there's
literally no pressure but I feel so much
pressure there we go got it oh oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] Oh dog [ __ ] dog [ __ ] ah [ __ ]
what have you done mr. sunroom or you
had Miranda's talisman for production
and yet you still tried to use me to
make the caretaker go away even though
he protects your husband he still wants
to get rid of you to avenge your sister
here that Joseph the journalist is
beginning to understand you're a bunch
of freaks
Oh Joseph Oh No oh don't worry I'll take
care of our guests I'll call the police
you screwed your backed into a corner
Jim there's no escape I'm gonna bleed
you like a pig and Joseph will drink
your blood
come here oh my god what have they done
is the police open up oh no
[Music]
so after taking drugs you went to the
hotel where your wife and daughter were
staying to kill them you're in deep [ __ ]
mr. son or more tell me this is a
nightmare I thought I'm gonna wake up
soon
my wife and I had our differences but
for me to kill her I don't believe that
it's too terrible ask about the pills
where did you get the drugs oh now I'm
here someone wearing a motorcycle helmet
delivers pizzas to me the pills are
slipped inside the pizza box with the
pills of any particular marking they
have horns printed on them he said
something about a mansion I had to go to
the Gorton's mansion to pad my article
on the paranormal it seems so real
Arianne yet de tolosa and the others I
couldn't make all that up did this dad
Lowe's make a wooden cow yes how did you
know that I'm asking the questions here
you ingested the so-called Minotaur drug
it's the latest blight we're trying to
eradicate those who take it become
minotaurs themselves the worst
labyrinths are not the ones made of
stone rather those within ourselves
you grappled with all of the Daedalus as
riddles but air Arianne most certainly
lent you a way out it was all a fantasy
the drug is also known to make users
highly aggressive lost everything why
would anyone invent [ __ ] like that to
create chaos and confusion in our
society spring you back to yourself we
can continue this discussion in a while
later
oh hi hello
even here in my cell you haunt me but
I'm not afraid anymore in a few hours
the drugs effects will subside subside
and you'll disappear I no more real than
you are Jim your existence is an
illusion you're nothing but lines of
code confined to a program are you
telling me this now are you trying to
drive me crazy
your story's almost over Jim it was time
for you to know the truth
you're the object of certain gazes like
an immense face covered in eyes they
watch your movements closely they take
pleasure in your trials and tribulations
I was designed as your tormentor to
entertain them does my weapon not remind
you of anything
[Music]
cynical wouldn't you say when all this
is over Jim some will easily forget you
like so many other fictional characters
that's bull I won't listen to you I'll
take away your skepticism by connecting
you to you one of the players oh oh stop
it stop it you'll stop it
let me out oh boy
oh well here I am again
[Music]
okay
oh where oh oh
[Music]
Oh
oh wow it was all a nightmare hahaha
just a [ __ ] nightmare I know you can
still hear me the pills not here anymore
I took that crap as blood spatter in the
photo of course as blood you just banged
your head on the table did I kill my
family
you're still hallucinating you throw up
that pizza and then fell asleep that's
all she's not answering the phone
calm down you think you killed them and
came then came back to finish your slice
of pizza come on don't be stupid get on
my head I didn't want to know what
really happened I'll go back to the
hotel where my wife we're still going
what the [ __ ] this time I won't make the
mistake of leaving without my gun no
don't what wait what don't take a gun
that sounds bad don't don't do that
but take a shower later you Jim you're
in a loop don't bother stay here with me
Seinfeld's on tonight come on ok ok I
don't feel like cooking right now fridge
is empty oh it's all the same thing I
said before [ __ ] can I stay with you
what I felt alright anyway so yeah ok
Miranda Miranda ha ha Kabir Kabir Kabir
it was just a poster Oh last show
does it penis ferno's was oh you're
completely lost all mixed up I'd rather
not be in your head oh but wait hahaha
I don't find that funny let me move move
if you continue the story will end in
the loop we'll start over again go back
to your apartment oh don't
I'm not someone's puppet let me go
believe me there's nothing good for you
further on I've made up my mind let's
play a little game then Jim ha ha ha ohh
ohh ohh ohh ohh
ok I'm moving woof aah all right Oh Oh
God
right I don't want to shoot cuz you know
just in case but here we go
okay here's a fun game oh that's oh wait
wait wait
Oh with the numbers important probably
oh oh okay
green and purple that's what I'm gonna
be looking for oh I see
okay I got you green and purple okay
green and purple green purple 1524 there
we go
[Music]
okay I think I'm doing it Oh point
goodbye hahaha
Jim why well that's cool I love the
ASCII event they got there you're
condemning us both to relive these
events for eternity this is all in my
head is it 2 1 7 after a car ride
lasting a few minutes I introduced
myself to the receptionist to find out
my wife's room number the doors open
Brenda
I
I love you
[Music]
we all that was a handmade what
if some of it was handmade
[Music]
wonderful game wonderful stories super
confusing at the end but I think it's by
design like I it's supposed to be by
design he's trapped like he wasn't lying
is trapped like in in a in a maze of his
own design inside his own head like
that's that's the truth of it but that's
such a good game it was so fun from
start to finish it was scary but then it
was funny too it just was entertaining
it just kept me going that was such a
good game though such a good game oh it
was so good [ __ ] I'm putting this on
YouTube [ __ ] this is so good that was so
good for every part of that was good
[ __ ] [ __ ] yup just so good I give no
complaints about it I have no complaints
none I've no complains about that god
that was fun god I want more God good
God who like koala
what was it koala something that made it
[ __ ] so good it's Ben's Oh Jim your
ordeal doesn't end here someone will
inevitably start a new game
inception horn blah
Oh Doh at pick so all I'm going to
follow at pixel all right [ __ ] now
that was such a good game just oh my god
everyone go fall a pixel wall everyone
tweeted pixel wall up like such a good
good game so thank you everybody I'm
like I love this I love this 100% I love
this I love this absolutely love this
straight-up no joke loved it developer
make more games like this maybe there
were multiple endings maybe there were
multiple endings maybe there were and
that's awesome if there were but thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you thought down the
comments below and as always I'll see
you in the next video bye bye